the federal government agreed early this
year Syrian refugees will be granted
residents in Germany for at least two
years what do germans think of this
humanitarian act so i think we could
take on more than currently planned I
think it's too little when you hear that
over a million have fled this ad Scotty
does it's a question of how many people
can be accommodated in the areas where
the refugee camps are located I think
the number is right as it is if you
think is the soul which decreases can I
don't listen man we could take on a few
more serious neighboring countries have
taken on hundreds of thousands and
they're not as wealthy as we are ed
garston is helping five thousand
refugees enough forty-seven percent say
yes twenty-seven percent say it's not
enough twenty-two percent think it
should be less isn't it on Germany's a
rich country why shouldn't we take on
more we've got enough money to support
them talking over northgate done Elvis
sniffing it's a question of how many I
think we have to help by any means we
can and I wouldn't set an upper or lower
limit for this we're on a home run
you